hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Manuel Samuel now I
know it's been a while since the last
episode and I apologize for that I may
have already talked about it but this
past week has been awesome in terms of
me making videos and all that sort of
stuff and I meant to get back to it much
sooner because I actually adore this
game it is stupid and don't hit that
bird
don't hit that bird okay good I thought
I was gonna hit Oh God
and I meant to get back to it a lot to
automatic gearbox into a manual one for
the funds
hey yo Roenick or what how at this point
sam notices the death isn't really a
nice guy yeah no not really
guess I should teach you how to drive a
stick huh I think I already know I
soaked when starting the car you want to
press down the clutch pedal nobody has
clutched anything for years
what is this mostly oxide I don't know
what that means right clutch while you
have it oh good the gas you know I may
have spoken too soon about this being it
let go of the clutch the car will stop
moving in this yeah good job dude Oh
game is useless as do you look Nami okay
now just stop you gotta move your right
foot to the brake pedal the left for us
he means well Oh God
okay I may have spoken too soon about
this game being charming and fun because
apparently I'm not gonna be able to do a
whole lot of this seriously
press it down if stopping a go dude nice
nice driving again max I showed you okay
alright we'll do as soon as I remember
to breathe and blink properly while I'm
doing this
urban Durham I know how to drive a
manual we turn left and right with your
arm
huh hey oh boy oh boy
drive faster you gotta use the stick how
am I gonna do the stick to upshift Oh
found the clutch and then yank the stick
Hey
left obviously you can't turn left when
your hand be on the stake why turn left
you have to move your hand back to the
steering wheel yard okay and show Sam
and the Lord of damnation are on their
merry way towards a new adventure
together kuzey okay nope that ain't work
and I probably got a downshift back to
first gear cuz I know how this works
okay here we go
lady on the road huh go ride bro I'm
going right I can't go right I did I did
stop huh that old lady has so many
cameras on her face why I almost killed
that lady she ain't due for another a
few hours okay if you kill somebody
before their time because I messed up
your motoring skills I will be in deep
feces okay so keep your eyes on the road
it's almost Carol one I'll stop the car
yo hmm but then you'll have to start it
all over again with the clutching biz
hey you'd be good to go
okay I'm gonna be able to do is for M&A
dude clearly wondering wildest Bisby
habit will be yeah truth bro it'd be all
part of bureaucratic bull feces the
shreds of life you give to those
gatekeepers to get into hell right yo
the shreds of life you give to those
gatekeepers to get into hell yeah they'd
be distributed between the bank of hell
and Satan oh yeah dude
go lamb first as I was saying oh yeah
dude the big s yeah don't be distracted
Bank of Hell distributes their share as
salary among the site dude yeah anyway
then the Bank of Hell distributes their
share as salary among the citizens of
do you know how much my salary be maybe
yo as I was saying a little less than a
burger flipper at Mickey demons yo and a
little more than an elementary school
teacher
you know what I'd be saying up high hey
a soul has one maybe two shreds on him
headin on his life quality okay happy
that gray cloud in the middle of the
road
oh btw that the a whole school of old
ladies get ready ah yo go ah right ah
left ah yo right okay Han
what be up with all those old ladies
today bro pattern a hey saying never
gonna make it to work on time with all
these grannies everywhere dude what do
you say we take a short no I don't want
to sure get bro
Ted Sandro what okay did I do it and so
Sam drives the car to a place he has
never been before
okay a cold Bridge Street
I hope it'd be safe here and no say
crazy gang members here ah si si I'm
gonna quit breathe crazy gang members Oh
crazy gang members hey excuse me
you'd be a crazy gang member how do you
worry I know we're the crazy gang
members being to death surprised and
Sam's relieved hey gang members are
lying dead on the ground what did they
kill each other and it notices a
distinct silhouette in the distance okay
deal bro why be there okay I guess we're
done is contention and enmity bloodshed
and hostility per a life and strike
ruggle battle whoa ohyes neither wearing
dumb clothes nor doing kick flips nice
she is just standing after a job well
done man holy feces holy face is it me
huh
okay Priya Oh be cool okay just don't be
yourself
Hey whoa how would be going BAE wanna
hit your ride and these sweet wheels
why don't wait why does this person have
a skull face and also boobs oh that's
the only thing that I'm not getting on
this everything else I'm fine with hey
how you doing take me to the metro okay
ready man we're often mallette m'lady
Mouton m'lady gonna blink and breathe
don't mind me he supposed to like reap a
bunch of people go ahead
I was I was then I got bored so now I
hang out with my buddy Sammy I'm it
right Sammy yeah hell yeah here whoa man
all right Thank You classic Chanel let's
go I don't know how I'm helping but okay
all right well here we go then so
instead of guiding endless amounts of
confused souls to the afterlife you
waste time with this dumb ugly mortal
stop here Oh fine Jesus yeah why is
there war on the streets right outside
new Samuels health I'm not sure I'm on
top of everything here but all right
whatever
hey you want a cigarette
we're so annoying I'm trying to quit
wait
fine give me one hate you go right here
stop here oh geez
like that why is she concerned about
smoking are we gonna beat pestilence and
all the other ones too
alright alright I'm a good driver this
is a weird day for Samuel hey guess what
I totally landed a kick kick today take
a left and it's wrong with you I take
them next
I was trying stop here okay there you go
jeezum I don't know if I should be okay
with this yeah alright okay we'll just
carry on with your wanton murder okay
and your cigarette that seems to be
burning a hole in my car really landed a
kickflip yeah well I almost landed a
kickflip wish you know him and can do a
frontside kickflip
stop here you got it why am I going so
fast anyway do I even need to go this
fast I mean I know I'm overachieving
here let's go
you got it let me just take another
breathe blinky breath break off we go
milady Makdessi cram Osby bye
oh no I'll keep it in second gear yo ah
ah right why are the grandmas in a
war-torn area ah never began using those
grannies stop here this is where I get
off
okay all right goodbye I'll see you read
whatever all right goodbye
bro bro bro you got to play cool man bro
Oh Gibby so you'll be getting late for
work bro
you can't be coming on so strong you can
if we gonna make it go
I don't know if I can hang on I gotta
figure out my wheels there we go
cars began huh I can go pretty hard go
faster faster
I'm going fast this is this maximum
speed I know this is his maximum speed
faster dude get up to fifth gear I am in
fifth gear waiting am I need a guy you
can't flip with war step on it I am Oh
feces stop stop okay
oh okay did we kill somebody
oh please let it just be a rock or a
hipster or something
okay Ryan goes out the door to see what
happened yeah he only has to follow
death's crying voice oh hi oh no this
guy was in do doesn't do what bi gonna
do
hey wait a minute hey Sam can I borrow
your last shred of life no twice it yeah
I didn't blink it all no not uh caving
in on myself there's no way you're gonna
give mom's red laughs here you go happen
I'll breathe Michael blink no yes we're
doing this nope
yeah we're doing this of course we're
doing this why wouldn't we be doing this
you're not gonna get my breath
shred alive shred breath shred breath no
no no no nope a No why would we I mean
it's obvious the shredded life is very
valuable to me so why would I readily
give it up surd
so death whoever's proven to be a dick
hello Sam Sammy Sammy are you set Sam
damn damn [ __ ] this guy hold on Sam
hold on hold on grab my hand
hey Ryan hold on my head oh boy Harry
there I guess blink all right ah okay
fine
yoyoyo let's do a deal that we can steal
yada yada yada
slap your salmon 57 times in 24 hours or
you'll be dead forever now get out of
here oh you talking about masturbation I
just had to anyway let's get out of here
weird okay yeah a little weird I mean I
don't even know if that would be
possible 57 times Felicia in Robocop Inc
where they produce automatic robots for
fun games and most importantly safety
okay finally Sam makes it to work well
don't leave I having the most terrifying
morning of his life okay baggles towards
the entrance okay shaky after the events
of his trip all right
yeah sounds pretty good but either way
this is gonna have to wait until the
next episode I am gonna finish this up
very soon so you can expect really
cooler videos of this coming out in the
near future so thank you everybody so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next video bye